good behavior is the last refuge of
mediocrity
human behavior flows from three main
sources desire emotion and knowledge
we change other people's behavior by
changing our own
[Music]
you can create beauty with your attitude
your behavior your actions
it's all up to you
[Music]
do not let the behavior of others
destroy your inner peace
[Music]
one thing i believe strongly in this
life is that you don't reward bad
behavior
[Music]
behavior is the mirror in which everyone
shows their true image
[Music]
most bad behavior comes from insecurity
[Music]
the less you respond to negative people
the more peaceful your life will
be if you want to change attitudes start
with a change in your behavior
the world is my church my actions are my
prayers my behavior is my creed
[Music]
the best apology is changed behavior
[Music]
anti-social behavior is a trait of
intelligence in a world full of
conformists
[Music]
you create your beauty through your
behavior your actions and your attitude
[Music]
love is a learned behavior
to show love is to know it deep in your
soul
[Music]
take a minute to look at your goals and
your performance see if your behavior
matches your goals
[Music]
good behavior in children isn't magic
it's a skill that can be learned just
like any other skill
[Music]
if you copy the negative behavior of
those you interact with it brings you
down to their level
[Music]
your beliefs don't make you a better
person your behavior does
[Music]
be plus have
equals behave
you will experience your success when
you behave accordingly
be and you shall have
[Music]
childishness comes almost as naturally
to a man as to a child
[Music]
don't give money to people who can't
handle it well you'll just enable bad
behavior
if you want to change the attitudes of
others
start with a change in your behavior
[Music]
you can't control other people
you can only control your reactions to
them
[Music]
you are always responsible for how you
act no matter how you feel
[Music]
good behavior can cover a lack of beauty
but beauty can never cover a lack of
good behavior
there is no better test of a man's
integrity than his behavior when he is
wrong
[Music]
the problem with merely tethering your
bad behavior is that eventually you'll
drop the chain
[Music]
we tend to judge others by their
behavior and ourselves by our intentions
acceptance without expectations is less
stressful
[Music]
no one is born with greed prejudice
bigotry patriotism or
hatred be the same person privately
publicly and personally
[Music]
the most important thing in changing
human behavior is the person's
motivation
[Music]
an ounce of behavior is worth a pound of
words
you mainly feel the way you think
[Music]
historically sociology has its main
roots in politics and the philosophy of
history
[Music]
kids don't remember what you try to
teach them they remember who you are
even at its most perceptive sociology
deals with abstractions
social media is about psychology more
than technology
[Music]
one cannot be deeply responsive to the
world without being often saddened
a negative judgment gives you more
satisfaction than praise provided it
smacks of jealousy
[Music]
your behavior is a choice it isn't who
you are
keep your words positive because your
words become your behavior
this is all teaching is arranging
contingencies that bring changes in
behavior
the way of a miracle worker is to see
all human behavior as one of two things
either love
or a call for love
[Music]
we must not demonstrate any arrogance
and we must refrain from any irrational
or undemocratic behavior
no matter how you behave with people
around you
they will love you according to their
need and their mood
[Music]
people don't change their behavior
unless it makes a difference for them to
do so
[Music]
you can never make the same mistake
twice because the second time you make
it
it's not a mistake it's a choice
[Music]
violent behavior exists in one
psychological makeup much deeper than
the level that receives information from
television or movies
relationships never die a natural death
they are murdered by attitude behavior
ego
hidden benefits or ignorance
some people will notice the change in
your attitude towards them but won't
notice it's their behavior that made you
change
[Music]
the behavior of an individual is
determined not by his racial affiliation
but by the character of his ancestry and
his cultural environment
[Music]
when attitude is changed thought is
changed
when thought is changed behavior is
changed
when behavior is changed actions are
changed
and results are changed
time decides who you meet in life your
heart decides who you want in life
your behavior decides who stays in your
life
a wise man is superior to any insults
that can be put upon him
and the best reply to unseemly behavior
is patience and moderation
it's better to hang out with people
better than you
pick out associates whose behavior is
better than yours and you'll drift in
that direction
[Music]
gentlemanly behavior isn't just opening
doors
to make an impression
you have to be concerned about a lady's
needs as much as you are about your own
needs
[Music]
a lot of comic actors derive their main
force from childish behavior
most great comics are doing such silly
things you'd say
that's what a child would do
[Music]
[Music]
you